go down the page so this guy's a little
Messier isn't it right because we've got
a more complicated object we've got a
parabola but I want to think in the same
way and see if I can work out the shape
of this thing okay what was the first
thing I looked at when I was doing this
there were a couple of features that
were important to me the x-intercepts
very good right now I had two
x-intercepts here that one and that one
right here just so happens I actually
have how many x-intercepts can you
captain nextdoor you're right
yep you miss exit Scott yeah yeah mrs.
Lee's I hope yep you see that do you see
the three x-intercepts do you see them
one two three so I'm going to use each
one I'm going to use them one at a time
let's just go from left to right shall
we okay so here's the first one now zero
plus something else you see that's
vertically just below it just there
see that's not there now you can see
that this is not a precise spot is it
it's not like nicely on the gridlines
okay but that's okay that's all right
zero plus some of the thing I don't know
what does it look like 3/4 or something
like that okay so whatever that value
it's negative sorry negative 3/4
whatever that value happens to be when I
add these two graphs together 0 plus
something else will give me something
else so I'm going to go through there
are you ok with that
I've got to keep on going from left to
right he's the next x-intercept right if
I look vertically am i above or below
below so I'm gonna go down to here okay
and I do actually go on a grid line now
what's the Y value down there that's
negative - isn't it so I'm going to put
a cross there 0 plus that will give you
that okay and then I've got to go all
the way across the y-axis to get to this
next intercept over here am i above or
below now I got up right so I'm gonna
get up to here something like that okay
like so okay so we're coming to the
whole shape at a minute okay so you got
this guy up here right again it's not on
a nice neat spot but no big deal 0 plus
some other thing will be some other
thing are you ok with that
now there are these three
points and before we got three points
and you're like oh this is all in a
straight line this is nice but this is
clearly not in a straight line is it so
just to make sure I'm confident I'm
gonna put a little extra information on
here okay let's have a look at the
y-axis can you look at the y-axis with
me I'm gonna use a different color here
who on the y-axis you got this value and
this value do you see those can you read
off for me
what's this X Y value up here it's one
and then this one down here negative
three what I'm doing with these two
graphs is I'm adding them together so
one plus negative three should give me
negative two so sort of in the middle
like that do you see that so my graph is
going to go through negative two
okay yeah question yeah so you literally
can pick anywhere on here right anywhere
you could put like a ruler up against
here which I didn't bring with me you
can put a rule up against you and say
okay this Plus this whatever that
happens to be and it's for ads okay it's
alright I'm not that fast right in fact
I'm gonna do one more an interesting one
over here on the left hand side do you
notice just have a look at this point
here with me here this line here right
what's this Y value here it's one what's
this Y value here it's just below it
it's negative one right so we're adding
these together what happens when you add
one and negative one you get zero right
so I'm just going to draw that in one
plus negative one they kind of meet
exactly in the middle add zero okay so
now have a look at our red crosses do
you feel like we've got enough
information to draw this thing I think
we've got roughly okay so I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm going to do my very best
I'd highly encourage if you don't
already have a pencil in your hand this
is quite hard to draw accurately get a
pencil out because that if you get wrong
no big deal okay in fact I'm very like
we gotta get me strong so I'll do it to
my very best I think this is the kind of
shape I'm getting right something like
this
what do you think of that I mean it's
not it's not the greatest it's not my
greatest work okay but it goes through
all of my red crosses right you can see
why it goes through and the shape that
it traces out and in fact there's
another fun spot here a point that we
didn't like actually draw on but I want
you to notice have a look at this spot
here there we go
I put a ruler up right against this spot
where my red graph the one I just kind
of guessed that right it that's the
x-intercept right what do you notice
about our original graphs F and G or F
and G I can't never which one's fish
what do you notice about those two
graphs when I put the ruler up against
it
yeah two and negative two and they
exactly cancel out they give you zero
does that make sense
so you can see how thank you mrs. Lee's
you can see how visually you're getting
that x-intercept by getting the two
spots where you're like exactly above
and below the same amount okay so this
is what the shape looks like now
let's confirm just like we did before
what happens if we think about this
algebraically okay so I'm getting did I
give you the right graph I'm just
thinking oh yeah I did okay cool
I'm thinking about y equals the sum of
these two f of X plus G of X and I'm
just going to substitute in what I know
f of X G of X what they're actually
equal to so I've got x squared minus
three that's the first function and then
I'm adding it Oh hold on a second
did I get this right sorry I'm just
thinking to myself it explained most
three oh yeah yeah yeah no sorry I'm
just um I'm just remembering my algebra
funny okay so this is just what I've
just substituted in what f of X is what
G of X is so I'm going to get x squared
plus X there minus two right there there
are no x squared terms to collect no X
terms that's just it right now this
object here if I gave this to you is the
first question what would you do with
this what were your instinct to be to
factorize right so I'm looking for a
pair of numbers they add two they add to
one and they multiply to negative two so
my pair of numbers will be X plus two
plus two is one of them and X minus one
now does that gel with what we drew on
the graph have a look over there right
what are the x-intercepts that you can
read off the red graph this one is one
which right which corresponds to that
guy over there right and then the other
x-intercept over here at negative two it
corresponds to this guy right you came
with that so you see how I've confirmed
what I got visually through my algebra
okay